TONIGHT, HOPEFUL ENTREPRENEURS
WHO BELIEVE THEY HAVE
THE NEXT BIG BUSINESS IDEA
WILL ENTER THE SHARK TANK
SEEKING THE FINANCIAL BACKING
TO MAKE THEIR DREAMS
COME TRUE.
THERE. THAT'S CALLED KICK BUTT.
THIS IS ONE OF OUR MOVEMENTS.
THIS IS HOW I KEEP
MY ADONIS FIGURE IN SHAPE.
YOU ARE DEFINITELY
BUILT LIKE A GOD‐‐
BUDDHA, TO BE EXACT.
(laughs)
THE SHARKS ARE READY TO INVEST
USING THEIR OWN MONEY,
BUT ONLY FOR THE RIGHT PERSON
WITH THE RIGHT IDEA.
HOW MUCH DO YOU LOVE MONEY?
DO YOU LOVE IT AS MUCH AS I DO?
PROBABLY NOT.
BUT FIRST, THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST CONVINCE A SHARK
TO INVEST THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR...
MOMMY!
OR THEY'LL WALK AWAY
WITH NOTHING.
I'M GETTING THIS STRANGE FEELING
YOU DON'T LIKE ME.
I DO LIKE YOU. I JUST DON'T
KNOW THAT I CAN WORK WITH YOU.
(sharks laugh)
AND IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GOOD IDEA,
THEY'LL FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A PIECE OF IT.
I WAS SORT OF TENDERIZING YOU
FOR MY OFFER.
I CAN BEAT THE OFFER.
OOH!
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
I WOULD LIKE TO COME IN HALF.
(laughs)
LESLIE, I WANT IN
ON THAT DEAL.
OH! (laughs) OH!
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
KEVIN O'LEARY
IS A VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO STARTED A SOFTWARE BUSINESS
IN HIS BASEMENT,
WHICH EVENTUALLY SOLD
FOR $3.2 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN
IS A FIERY REAL ESTATE MOGUL
WHO TURNED A $1,000 LOAN
INTO AN EMPIRE
WORTH HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS.
KEVIN HARRINGTON
IS THE KING OF INFOMERCIALS.
HIS GENIUS MARKETING
OF PRODUCTS
HAS AMASSED
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN SALES.
DAYMOND JOHN
TURNED RAGS TO RICHES
WITH HIS CLOTHING BRAND FUBU,
WHICH HAS GROSSED
OVER $6 BILLION.
AND ROBERT HERJAVEC,
A TECHNOLOGY TYCOON
WHO SOLD HIS INTERNET COMPANIES
FOR OVER $350 MILLION.
(man) ♪ THE BEST THINGS
IN LIFE ARE FREE ♪
♪ BUT THAT AIN'T REALLY
GOOD ENOUGH FOR ME ♪
♪ I NEED MONEY ♪
♪ THAT'S WHAT I WANT ♪
♪ WHAT I WANT ♪
(exhales deeply)
FIRST INTO THE SHARK TANK
IS LESLIE HAYWOOD,
A SOUTHERN HOUSEWIFE
WITH A CHARMING IDEA.
♪♪
HEY, HONEY, I'M HOME.
I AM LESLIE HAYWOOD,
STAY‐AT‐HOME WIFE AND MOTHER,
AND I CREATED A PRODUCT
FOR ANYONE THAT LOVES GRILLING.
WITH ALL OF THIS GOING ON,
IT IS HARD TO KEEP TRACK
OF EVERYTHING ON THE GRILL.
OKAY, WHO HAD
THE SPICY CHICKEN?
BUT MY PRODUCT IS THE SOLUTION
TO EVERY GRILLER'S PROBLEM.
WHEN I AM NOT BUSY BEING
SHORT‐ORDER COOK,
HEAD NOSE‐WIPER, TAXI DRIVER,
I AM VERY BUSY
BEING FOUNDER, PRESIDENT,
C.E.O., MARKETING GURU
AND BOOKKEEPER
FOR MY GRILLING GADGET EMPIRE.
I ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN OUT
TO "SHARK TANK" ONCE BEFORE,
AND RIGHT BEFORE I WAS GETTING
READY TO WALK IN THE SHARK TANK,
I GOT A CALL FROM MY MOM.
(voice breaking) AND MY FATHER
HAD PASSED AWAY VERY SUDDENLY
AND UNEXPECTEDLY.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, UM,
ONE OF THE LAST THINGS
HE SAID WAS,
HE ASKED MY MOM
NOT TO CALL ME...
(normal voice) BECAUSE HE DIDN'T
WANT TO BE THE REASON
WHY I MISSED OUT
ON THIS OPPORTUNITY.
I HAD TO COME HOME,
AND WE HAD TO BURY HIM.
IT WAS
THE MOST DEVASTATING THING
I HAD EVER BEEN THROUGH.
A FEW WEEKS LATER,
I GOT THIS CALL
FROM THE "SHARK TANK,"
SAYING THAT I GOT
THIS SECOND CHANCE.
WHEN I WALK OUT THERE,
I KNOW THAT HE WILL BE WITH ME,
AND HE WILL BE CHEERING FOR ME
THE WHOLE WAY.
♪♪
HI.
I'M LESLIE HAYWOOD,
CREATOR OF GRILL CHARMS.
I'M SEEKING $50,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 25% EQUITY
IN MY COMPANY.
WHERE I COME FROM,
WE GRILL YEAR‐ROUND.
NOW I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE
EVER HAD THIS PROBLEM,
BUT WHEN YOU GO TO A COOKOUT
OR A BARBECUE,
AND YOU SERVE A PLATTER
FULL OF FOOD,
A LOT OF TIMES, YOU CAN'T TELL
WHICH IS WHICH.
YOU CAN'T TELL WHICH ONE IS RARE
AND WHICH ONE'S MEDIUM RARE.
OR MAYBE YOU HAVE
A SPICY PIECE OF CHICKEN,
BUT YOU WEREN'T PREPARED FOR IT,
AND IT LIGHTS YOU ON FIRE.
OR MAYBE YOU HAVE HEALTH
OR ALLERGY CONCERNS.
WELL, I HAVE INVENTED A PRODUCT
CALLED GRILL CHARMS
THAT SOLVE ALL OF THESE PROBLEMS
AND MORE.
THEY ARE
SOLID STAINLESS STEEL CHARMS
THAT YOU PUT IN YOUR FOOD
BEFORE YOU GRILL.
THERE'S FOUR COLLECTIONS
FOR DIFFERENT PURPOSES.
THE STEAK COLLECTION, WHICH IS
"MR" FOR MEDIUM RARE,
THEN YOU HAVE MEDIUM WELL,
ETCETERA.
THEN FOR THE SPICY COLLECTION,
YOU HAVE A PICTURE
OF A PEPPER ON FIRE
IF YOU LIKE IT HOT.
AND THEN THERE'S
TWO OTHER COLLECTIONS
FOR DIFFERENT PURPOSES.
WHERE DO YOU SELL THEM?
I'M IN, UH, 103 INDEPENDENT,
UH, RETAIL STORES
ACROSS THE U. S.,
CANADA AND SWEDEN.
WHO DOES THE SELLING?
I'M DOING THE SELLING.
(laughs)
SHE COULD SELL ANYTHING.
YOU'RE‐‐YOU'RE A SORT OF
ONE‐MAN SHOP, SO TO SPEAK.
I AM.
COULD WE SEE A SAMPLE
WHILE YOU'RE SPEAKING TO US?
OH, ABSOLUTELY. SURE, SURE.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES TODAY,
LESLIE?
WELL, I JUST STARTED HERE, SO
THIS PAST YEAR WE DID $60,000.
AND JUST TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA
ABOUT THE PASSION
AND DETERMINATION,
I WENT FROM
SPICY LIGHTBULB MOMENT‐‐
LITERALLY AT A DINNER PARTY
THAT I HOSTED‐‐
TO HAVING MY PRODUCT ON STORE
SHELVES IN A YEAR AND A HALF.
IN BETWEEN THAT TIME,
I HAD A LITTLE RUN‐IN WITH
BREAST CANCER AT THE AGE OF 34,
SO THAT SLOWED ME UP
JUST A LITTLE BIT.
WHOA! THAT SLOWED YOU UP
YES, BUT EVEN THAT
DIDN'T STOP ME.
(Barbara) LESLIE,
WHAT DOES THIS SELL FOR?
6 CHARMS‐‐THAT RETAILS
IN STORES FOR $19.95.
IT'S THE PERFECT GIFT ITEM.
SO YOU'VE GOT
THE GRILLING INDUSTRY,
THE GIFTING INDUSTRY,
THEN WE HAVE THE LICENSING.
EVERY SPORTS TEAM,
EVERY TAILGATER,
NEEDS THEIR OWN SET.
DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY GRILLS
GEORGE FOREMAN SOLD,
BY THE WAY?
100 MILLION GRILLS.
OKAY? SO GRILLING IS‐‐
IS HUGE, RIGHT?
IT IS HUGE.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO
WITH THE $50,000?
I AM GONNA USE THAT TO REALLY
WHOMP UP AT TRADE SHOWS,
'CAUSE IF YOU WANT TO RUN
WITH THE BIG DOGS,
YOU HAVE GOT TO‐‐
YOU GOTTA BARK.
AND THAT'S
WHAT I NEED TO DO.
EITHER THAT, OR OH, DIRECT
TO TV, YOU KNOW... (laughs)
I GOT MY‐‐
I GOT MY EYE ON YOU.
(O'Leary) YOU'RE THE REAL DEAL.
YOU GOT SOMETHING HERE.
THE CHALLENGE‐‐
IT'S‐‐IT'S NOT A‐‐
IT'S‐‐IT'S NOT REALLY
A COMPANY YET.
IT'S A PRODUCT,
AND ONE THAT'S WORKING.
WELL, IT'S FUNNY. I KNOW
A GUY WHO'S GOOD AT THAT.
SO...
(laughs)
BUT WAIT A SECOND, ROBERT.
YOU INTERRUPTED ME, AND I WAS
ABOUT TO MAKE AN OFFER.
(gasps)
OH, I'M SORRY. I DIDN'T MEAN
TO GET IN THE WAY OF YOUR OFFER.
GO AHEAD AND MAKE THE OFFER.
SILENCE, PLEASE.
UM, I WAS SORT OF TENDERIZING
YOU FOR MY OFFER.
I THINK WHAT I WOULD DO
IS I'D GIVE YOU $50,000
FOR 50% OF THE BUSINESS
OR THE PRODUCT,
WHICH IS
ALL IT IS RIGHT NOW.
MM‐HMM.
UM, I'M GONNA PUT
A 7% ROYALTY ON IT.
LESLIE.
YES.
I WOULDN'T TAKE HIS OFFER.
I CAN BEAT THE OFFER.
I CAN BRING MORE TO THE TABLE.
OKAY? 'CAUSE HE'S‐‐
HE SAYS, "IT'S NOT A BUSINESS,
IT'S A PRODUCT."
RIGHT. RIGHT.
A PRODUCT IS A BUSINESS.
RIGHT.
MY OFFER IS‐‐
YOU NEED THE MONEY,
BUT YOU NEED THE EXPERTISE.
AND I HAVE THE EXPERTISE
IN DEVELOPING THE TELEVISION,
THE INFOMERCIAL SIDE.
BUT I WOULD SAY I WOULD
GIVE YOU THE $50,000.
FORGET THE ROYALTY. BUT I DO
WANT 50% OF THE COMPANY.
LESLIE, I WANT IN
ON THAT DEAL.
(Leslie gasps)
KEVIN, I'M NOT SURE
YOU NEED ME,
BUT MAYBE I COULD PUT UP
MORE THAN HALF THE MONEY,
'CAUSE I THINK THIS IS ONE OF
THE BEST IDEAS WE'VE SEEN.
SO, KEVIN, WILL YOU LET ME IN
ON THAT DEAL IF I PUT UP...
$30,000 OF THE MONEY
AND WE EACH GET 25%?
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT,
WAIT, WAIT.
BEFORE THEY START
COLLUDING TOGETHER ON THE DEAL,
UM, I DO BELIEVE
THAT KEVIN‐‐THE NICE KEVIN‐‐
IS‐‐
(Leslie laughs)
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ME
AGAIN?
(sharks chuckle)
IS THE BEST PERSON
TO DO THE DEAL.
ROBERT HAS NO IDEA
ABOUT HOW TO SELL TO RETAILERS.
YOU KNOW, YOU EVER GO INTO
A STORE AND YOU SEE
"AS SEEN ON TV"?
OH, YEAH. OH, YEAH.
OKAY. SO THAT IS WHERE
MY ABILITY IS.
SO THIS COULD BE
IN STORES AS WELL.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO COME IN HALF,
AND, UM,
YOU DON'T NEED BAD KEVIN
OR PRETTY ROB...
(laughs)
IN THE DEAL.
WHY, THANK YOU FOR
CALLING ME PRETTY, DAYMOND.
THANK YOU FOR CALLING ME BAD.
WOW.
I'D LIKE TO GET‐‐
(Barbara) I JUST WANT
TO CLEAR THE FIELD A LITTLE.
I LOVE THE IDEA. YOU HAVE
FOUR GROWN MEN ROMANCING YOU,
HALF BECAUSE YOUR PRODUCT
IS GREAT,
AND HALF BECAUSE
YOU'RE SO DAMN PRETTY.
(all laugh)
BARBARA, I DIDN'T EVEN NOTICE
HOW PRETTY SHE WAS.
I'M SURE NOT.
I AM JUST ENAMORED
WITH THE PRODUCT. SO, KEVIN...
I'M OUT.
HARRINGTON.
YES.
I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR. YOU'VE
KICKED ME OUT OF THE DEAL?
IS THAT WHAT YOU'VE DONE? 'CAUSE
I WOULD LOVE TO PARTICIPATE.
UM...
I WANT PART OF THIS DEAL.
I HAVE TO SAY THIS, OKAY?
I'M GONNA DO THE TELEVISION.
DAYMOND CAN DO THE RETAIL.
AND IT‐‐AND I DON'T THINK
A THIRD PARTNER
IS GONNA MAKE SENSE HERE.
OH, FORGET THAT.
LESLIE, I'LL GIVE YOU
THE 50 GRAND FOR 25%,
EXACTLY LIKE YOU ASKED.
AND NO ASSISTANCE.
(Harrington chuckles)
HE WILL GIVE YOU
NO ASSISTANCE, LESLIE.
OH! (laughs) OH!
LESLIE, THERE'S OTHER
TV GUYS OUT THERE.
HE DOESN'T OWN THE MONOPOLY
FOR STUFF TO FLOG ON TV.
SO YOU GET 75% OF A SMALL PIE
WITH ROBERT.
YOU GET 50% OF A BIG PIE
WITH ME AND DAYMOND.
THEY BARELY LET HIM
IN RETAIL STORES TO SHOP...
(laughs)
LET ALONE‐‐LET ALONE
PUT SOME PRODUCT IN THERE.
I AM DISGUSTED
BY YOUR GREED.
I AM DISGUSTED BY IT.
WHAT HAPPENED TO MY OFFER?
WHAT AM I, CHOPPED LIVER
OVER HERE?
I DON'T LIKE THE ROYALTIES.
LESLIE, LET ME ASK YOU
A QUESTION.
WHEN YOU STARTED
YOUR BUSINESS...
YES.
DID YOU START IT
TO GIVE UP HALF OF IT?
I BUILT MY BUSINESS
OUT OF MY HOUSE
WITH CREDIT CARDS BY MYSELF...
RIGHT.
AND SOLD IT FOR $150 MILLION,
WHICH MAY BE SMALL TO KEVIN,
BUT I OWNED 100% OF IT.
LESLIE, WE ALL DID THAT.
LESLIE, LISTEN TO ME
FOR A SECOND.
THESE NUMBERS
ARE ROUNDING ERRORS.
I SOLD MY BUSINESS
FOR $3.2 BILLION.
AND THAT'S WHY HE'S TRYING
TO SCREW YOU ON A ROYALTY.
ABSOLUTELY NOT. NOISE, NOISE.
THIS STUFF IS ROUNDING ERRORS.
ALL RIGHT, LESLIE,
WE HAVE TWO DEALS...
OKAY.
'CAUSE WE ALL KNOW
KEVIN'S DEAL IS A WASTE OF TIME.
NO, IT ISN'T.
WE ALL KNOW KEVIN‐‐OKAY.
SO WE HAVE THREE DEALS.
WELL, THIS IS‐‐
THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE.
I MEAN, OF COURSE
I CAME OUT HERE,
AND I WAS GUNNIN' FOR YOU.
I‐I MEAN, REALLY.
I'M VERY SAD TO HEAR THAT.
THAT IS WHO
I INITIALLY THOUGHT
MY PRODUCT WOULD BE
A PERFECT FIT FOR.
BUT, YOU KNOW, I MEAN,
YOU GUYS HAVE JUST REALLY,
REALLY GIVEN ME
A LOT TO THINK ABOUT.
I THINK
I DO NEED TO STEP OUTSIDE
AND MULL THIS OVER
JUST FOR A MINUTE.
(Harrington) OKAY, PLEASE DO.
OKAY.
WE WANT YOU TO MAKE
THE RIGHT DECISION.
YOU'RE PRESSURING HER.
THAT IS ONE TOUGH WOMAN.
(telephone ringing)
Hello?
HI, HON.
GOOD NEWS, I THINK. (laughs)
I'VE GOT, UM,
ALL OF THE SHARKS,
UH, BUT ONE
FIGHTING OVER ME.
A COUPLE OF 'EM WANT
50% OF THE BUSINESS,
AND I JUST DON'T KNOW
IF I'M WILLING TO GIVE UP
THAT MUCH CONTROL.
AND THEN I'VE GOT ANOTHER SHARK
THAT WILL GIVE ME
EXACTLY WHAT I'M ASKING FOR,
BUT HE DOESN'T BRING
ENOUGH TO THE TABLE.
EVEN THOUGH THEY SAY
THAT THEY'RE NOT GONNA BUDGE,
I GOTTA GIVE IT ONE MORE SHOT.
I NEED THAT NUMBER TO COME DOWN
JUST A LITTLE BIT.
YOU'RE LIKE
LITTLE HIGH SCHOOL BOYS
GIGGLING ABOUT THE PRETTY GIRL.
(Robert) THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY NOT TRUE.
I STILL‐‐I REALLY HAVE
A PROBLEM WITH THE 50%.
LESLIE, HANG ON. ARE YOU
SAYING NO TO MY OFFER?
NO, NO, NO.
BUT I DO WANT THIS OFFER.
IT'S THE 50% THAT'S KILLING ME,
'CAUSE I REALLY‐‐THE EXPERTISE,
IT IS THERE.
IT REALLY IS THERE.
I'M GETTING THIS STRANGE FEELING
YOU DON'T LIKE ME.
I... (laughs)
I DO LIKE YOU.
I JUST DON'T KNOW
THAT I CAN WORK WITH YOU.
(sharks laugh)
OH!
ARE YOU KIDDING?
I LIKE HER EVEN MORE!
FINALLY, SOMEBODY'S
BEING HONEST.
COME ON.
YOU GOTTA BE KIDDING.
NO. Y‐YEAH.
MY OFFER IS‐‐IS 50%.
THERE IS NO OTHER OFFER.
THERE IS NO OTHER OFFER?
NO. THAT'S THE DEAL.
49?
NO, I CAN'T.
IT'S 50 OR NO DEAL.
I WOULD BE THE SAME‐‐
50 OR NO DEAL.
YOU'VE GOTTA MAKE A DECISION.
WHAT'S IT GONNA BE?
♪♪
LESLIE HAS TWO OFFERS
ON THE TABLE.
ROBERT IS OFFERING
WHAT SHE ASKED FOR‐‐
$50,000
FOR 25% OF THE BUSINESS.
DAYMOND AND KEVIN HARRINGTON
ARE ALSO OFFERING $50,000,
BUT THEY WANT
HALF OF HER BUSINESS.
HOWEVER, LESLIE HAD
HER HEART SET
ON MAKING A DEAL
WITH KEVIN HARRINGTON,
WHO'S SOLD BILLIONS
WITH HIS INFOMERCIALS.
MY OFFER IS‐‐IS 50%.
I WOULD BE THE SAME‐‐
50 OR NO DEAL.
WOW. THIS IS INTERESTING.
♪♪
MY OFFER STILL STANDS, LESLIE,
'CAUSE I BELIEVE IN YOU.
I THINK YOU'RE GONNA DO IT.
ANYBODY THAT COMES FROM
THEIR HOUSE AS A HOUSEWIFE,
STARTS ALL THIS,
BEATS CANCER ALONG THE WAY,
YOU'RE GONNA DO IT.
THIS IS ALL NOISE.
1% IS MINISCULE, OKAY? 'CAUSE
WE'RE‐‐WE'RE EQUAL PARTNERS.
DON'T‐‐DON'T LET 1%
BLOW THE DEAL.
HARRINGTON'S GONNA DUMP YOU
LIKE A COLD POTATO
IF THE PRODUCT DOESN'T SELL.
YOU KNOW THAT.
ENOUGH CHATTER.
LET'S DO IT.
WAIT. JUST BEFORE...
JUST BEFORE
YOU MAKE YOUR DECISION...
YOU'RE OUT.
NO, NO. I'M NOT FINISHED.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $50,000
FOR 20% OF THE BUSINESS
WITH MY ROYAL‐‐
OOH!
WITH MY ROYALTY STRUCTURE
IN PLACE, AND YOU'RE‐‐
THE FULL CONFIDENCE, BECAUSE
I WILL NOT BE A CONTROL PARTNER.
LESLIE, WHY DON'T YOU TELL
THIS GUY HE'S OUT?
YOU CAN'T STAND HIM.
GET RID OF HIM.
(laughs) OH, I D‐‐
LESLIE, YOU KNOW
WHAT SHE SAID ABOUT YOU
WHILE YOU WERE OUT THERE?
SHE SAID THE ONLY REASON
WE'RE TALKING TO YOU IS
'CAUSE YOU'RE A PRETTY WOMAN.
AND I FOUND THAT INSULTING.
I FOUND THAT INSULTING.
SHE'S SEXIST.
BARBARA!
YOU BELIEVE IN YOURSELF.
(Robert) MAKE A DECISION.
YOU KNOW YOU CAN DO IT.
I DO. I DO.
I JUST‐‐I DIDN'T GET
THIS FAR GIVING UP MY BABY.
AND I JUST CAN'T GIVE IT UP.
♪♪
I'M GONNA GO...
WITH ROBERT.
WHOO!
(Barbara) WHAT A SURPRISE.
IT'S THE RIGHT DECISION.
(Leslie) OH.
UNBELIEVABLE.
OHH.
YOU DID THE RIGHT THING.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
YOU SHOULD NEVER GIVE UP 50%.
I KNOW, I KNOW.
I JUST CAN'T. I CAN'T.
(Robert) YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU CAN'T DO IT.
UNBELIEVABLE.
WHAT A SURPRISE.
THANKS, LESLIE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU TRY
TO SCREW ME OVER, HARRINGTON.
OHH. (laughs)
I WENT IN THERE
GOING FOR KEVIN HARRINGTON,
'CAUSE I‐‐HE'S THE TV GUY.
THAT'S‐‐THAT'S WHO‐‐
WHO I THOUGHT THAT I NEEDED.
BUT THEN ROBERT, UH,
I JUST CONNECTED WITH HIM,
AND I REALLY THINK THAT HE HAS
MY BEST INTERESTS AT HEART,
AND, UH, I SO LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH HIM.
IT'S GONNA BE GREAT.
SHE MADE A CRAZY,
WRONG DECISION.
SHE DID NOT MAKE
A POOR DECISION.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND
THAT I HAVE SOLD
$6 BILLION WORTH OF PRODUCT
AROUND THE WORLD?
AND, WHAT, I'M SUPPOSED
TO BE IMPRESSED BY THAT?
YOU'RE BOTH BOZOS. I'M GONNA
CALL HER UP AND DO IT FOR 10%.
(laughs)
JUST WEEKS AGO,
WE MET ENTREPRENEUR
SUSAN KNAPP
AND WATCHED HER STRIKE A DEAL
WITH THE SHARKS.
I‐I WILL... SAY YES.
YES.
AHA. SHE'S GONNA SAY NO,
HUH, DAYMOND? HUH?
SHE'S GONNA REGRET IT.
HERE'S WHAT SHE'S UP TO NOW...
I AM HAPPY TO REPORT THAT AFTER
GOING INTO THE SHARK TANK
TO SAVE
MY GOURMET FOOD BUSINESS,
SALES HAVE SKYROCKETED.
THE SHARKS EVEN GOT ME
ON THE HOME SHOPPING NETWORK.
WE HAD 1,600 UNITS SOLD
IN ONE DAY.
I MADE THE CINNAMON PEAR JELLY
FOR FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
I MEAN, IT WAS GREAT.
(laughs)
OH, MY GOSH.
BEFORE BEING ON "SHARK TANK,"
MY SALES
WERE ONLY $8,000 A MONTH.
NOW THEY'RE
OVER $80,000 A MONTH.
(Harrington)
SUSAN IS A REAL PROFESSIONAL.
SHE'S BUILT
A HECK OF A BUSINESS.
AND THIS BUSINESS
IS GONNA TAKE OFF.
♪♪
NEXT UP ARE DAVID ADAMOVICH
AND TODD ROBBINS,
WHO WANT TO BRING
GOOD, CLEAN FUN
TO NEW YORK CITY'S
TIMES SQUARE.
♪♪
I'M TODD ROBBINS.
AND I'M DAVID ADAMOVICH.
WE'RE HERE FOR $300,000
AT A 20% EQUITY
IN THE FUNHOUSE.
YOU KNOW,
WHEN YOU HAVE AN IDEA
FOR SOMETHING NEW
AND EXCITING,
I WISH
FINDING THE MONEY FOR IT
WOULD BE AS EASY AS,
WELL, LIKE THAT.
BUT, OF COURSE, IT'S NOT,
SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE.
NOW AS YOU CAN GUESS, I HAVE
A LITTLE BACKGROUND IN MAGIC.
I'M ALSO
A SIDESHOW PERFORMER.
AND, DAVID, WHY DON'T YOU
LET THEM KNOW WHO YOU ARE?
I'M KNOWN
AS THE GREAT THROWDINI.
I AM THE WORLD'S FASTEST
AND MOST‐ACCURATE KNIFE THROWER.
SO I'LL JUST GIVE YOU...
WOW.
A LITTLE SAMPLE
OF WHAT I DO.
(Barbara) JEEZ.
WOW. THAT'S IMPRESSIVE.
WOW.
(David) THANK YOU.
I WANT TO DO THAT? CAN I
STAND THERE AND YOU DO THAT?
SURE.
(O'Leary)
YOU'RE GONNA STAND THERE?
(Todd and David
speaking indistinctly)
YOU ARE NUTS, DAYMOND.
(Harrington) WOW.
LOOK AT HIM.
LET'S GO.
OH. AAH!
(sharks laughing)
OH! MOMMY!
(O'Leary) MORE!
UH‐OH! YEAH!
OH. (laughs)
OOH!
I LIKE THAT. I LIKE THAT.
YOU DID GREAT.
SCARY. (laughs)
(Harrington speaking
indistinctly)
YOU ARE A MAJOR NUT BALL.
(Robert) THROWDINI,
THAT WAS IMPRESSIVE.
THANK YOU.
LAST YEAR, 35 MILLION PEOPLE
CAME TO THE TIMES SQUARE AREA
IN NEW YORK CITY.
SO WE ARE STARTING UP
A 25,000‐SQUARE‐FOOT,
UH, LIVE ENTERTAINMENT
AND AMUSEMENT ATTRACTION
CALLED THE FUNHOUSE
IN THE TIMES SQUARE AREA.
25,000 SQUARE FEET
IN THE MIDDLE OF NEW YORK?
YEAH, YEAH.
ARE YOU GUYS NUTS?
UNH‐UNH. NO.
NO.
THERE ARE FIVE AREAS‐‐
VENUES GOING ON
IN THE, UH, FUNHOUSE
THAT HAVE LIVE ENTERTAINMENT.
AND WE HAVE
A VAUDEVILLE CAFé.
THIS IS A 200‐SEAT RESTAURANT
THAT FEATURES A STAGE
WITH, UH, WORLD‐CLASS
VARIETY ENTERTAINERS‐‐
JUGGLERS, PLATE SPINNERS,
ACROBATS, KNIFE THROWERS.
WE HAVE AN OLD‐STYLE SIDESHOW
FEATURING SWORD SWALLOWING,
FIRE EATING.
A LOUNGE AREA THAT HAS
MAGICIANS DOING CLOSE‐UP MAGIC‐‐
CARDS, COINS, TRICKS‐‐
OKAY, WE GET IT.
HOW MUCH IS IT GONNA COST?
HOW ARE WE GONNA MAKE MONEY?
OKAY,
IT'S VERY, VERY SIMPLE.
WE ARE GOING TO GIVE THAT
ALL FOR A $15 ADMISSION PRICE.
WE ANTICIPATE THAT IN
THE FIRST YEAR OF OPERATION,
IT'S GONNA GROSS
$9.4 MILLION.
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
ATTRACT CUSTOMERS?
IT'S VERY SIMPLE.
FIRST, THE‐‐THE EXTERIOR OF
THE‐‐THE VENUE WILL BE SUCH
THAT PEOPLE WILL BE ABLE TO
FIND IT IF THEY KNOW ABOUT IT.
SO WALK‐BY TRAFFIC?
YEAH, IT'S ALL FOOT TRAFFIC.
WHAT'S IT GONNA COST YOU
TO BUILD THAT WHOLE FA‐‐
25,000 SQUARE FEET?
WE'VE CAPITALIZED THE START‐UP
ON IT AS ABOUT $1.5 MILLION.
(Robert) WOW.
WHAT IS IT GONNA COST YOU
TO STAY OPEN EACH MONTH
ONCE THAT 1 AND A HALF
IS IN?
WELL, THE‐‐THE ANNUAL EXPENSE
IS... IT'S SIZEABLE. IT IS‐‐
(Robert) WHAT IS IT?
$7.4 MILLION.
YOWZA.
WOW.
YEAH. YEAH.
(O'Leary) WHOA.
THE PITCH
IS TO BUY INTO A BUSINESS
AND JUST HOPE LIKE CRAZY
THEY BUY THE TICKETS.
YEAH.
LIKE, YOU COULD JUST SIT THERE,
HUDDLE AROUND THE FIRE AND GO,
"PLEASE MAKE IT HAPPEN.
PLEASE. I BELIEVE! I BELIEVE!"
AND IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
IN TODAY'S MARKET?
YOU SHOULD JUST THROW KNIVES
AT EACH OTHER, REALLY.
I'M OUT.
IT‐‐IT'S NOT ACTUALLY
A MILLION AND A HALF, KEVIN.
BARBARA UNCOVERED IT.
YOU HAVE TO GIVE THEM
THE MILLION AND A HALF,
OR THEY HAVE TO GET IT,
THEN YOU'RE ON THE HOOK
FOR THE $7.4 MILLION.
THIS IS A HUGE RISK,
AND NOT KNOWING WHETHER
THE MODEL WORKS OR NOT,
IS‐‐IS JUST WAY TOO RISKY
FOR ME. I'M OUT.
TO ME, IT'S A COIN TOSS.
I DON'T LIKE TO TAKE
THAT KIND OF A RISK,
SO I'M OUT.
I THINK
YOU'RE UNDERESTIMATING
A LARGE COST THAT WE HAVEN'T
DISCUSSED HERE AT ALL.
I'VE HEARD NOTHING ABOUT
THE BRANDING OF IT,
WHICH I THINK IS KEY,
SO I'M SO FEARFUL YOU'RE GONNA
LOSE A LOT OF MONEY.
SO I'M OUT.
YOU KNOW,
THERE'S AN OLD SAYING‐‐
THE HIGHER
A MONKEY CLIMBS A TREE,
THE MORE YOU SEE HIS ASS.
I'M OUT.
WELL, THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR LISTENING TO US.
DAVID, YOU HAD A KNIFE
IN FRONT OF YOU.
OF COURSE WE WOULD LISTEN.
EXACTLY, YEAH.
(David) AH, WELL.
GOOD LUCK.
THEY WERE SCARED. IT SEEMED
LIKE THEY WERE SCARED.
I MAY BE READING THAT WRONG,
BUT...
UH, THEY SEEMED WIMPS.
I'M SORRY.
BOY, THAT WAS SO RISKY.
CAN YOU IMAGINE THAT?
YOU PUT UP A MILLION
AND A HALF DOLLARS,
AND THE NEXT DAY, IT'S GONE.
I DID LEARN SOMETHING, THOUGH.
I LEARNED HOW TO THROW KNIVES.
WHAT WAS THE KEY, KEVIN?
I'M GONNA SHOW YOU NOW,
ROBERT, WHAT I FIGURED OUT.
BARBARA, PLEASE,
BE MY GUEST.
NO, THANK YOU. PRACTICE.
YOU KNOW THOSE EARRINGS?
I'LL PIN THEM TO THE WOOD.
(Barbara and Daymond) WHOA!
♪♪
I'M DEDE BARBANTI.
AND I'M KATHY LAMM.
AND WE ARE FROM
LADERA RANCH, CALIFORNIA.
I WANT TO GO ON YOUR BACK.
(Dede) AFTER HAVING
MY‐‐MY THIRD BABY,
I WEIGHED OVER 200 POUNDS,
AND, UM, I SEPARATED
FROM MY HUSBAND.
IT WAS A REALLY,
REALLY BAD TIME IN MY LIFE.
ELBOWS ARE OUT.
I NEED A WAY
TO SUPPORT MY CHILDREN,
SO I TOOK ALL MY TRAINING
AND DANCING
IN MARTIAL ARTS,
AS A CHOREOGRAPHER,
AND I PUT TOGETHER
BOOGIE BOX FITNESS.
IT'S KATHY FROM BOOGIE BOX.
I WAS INTRODUCED TO DEDE
BY A MUTUAL ACQUAINTANCE,
AND I IMMEDIATELY
FELL IN LOVE
WITH WHAT SHE HAD
PUT TOGETHER,
AND I WANTED TO GET
BOOGIE BOX FITNESS OUT
TO THE REST OF THE WORLD.
HERE WE GO.
WE WANT TO SHOW THE WORLD
THAT IF TWO MOMS
CAN FULFILL THEIR DREAMS
AND PROVIDE
FOR THEIR CHILDREN‐‐
IF WE CAN DO IT,
ANYBODY CAN DO IT.
ANYBODY CAN. YEAH.
♪♪
(lightning crackles)
(dance music playing)
HIT IT!
BOOGIE JUMP. LET'S GO.
♪♪
BOOGIE PUMP. HUH.
HIT IT!
WHOO!
MOVE IT BACK.
HO!
♪♪
(song ends)
WHOO!
YEAH.
(Daymond) YEAH.
ALL RIGHT.
HI, I'M DEDE.
I'M THE C. E. O. AND CREATOR
OF BOOGIE BOX FITNESS.
AND I'M KATHY.
I'M DEDE'S BUSINESS PARTNER
AND I AM
THE CHIEF OPERATOR OFFICER
OF BOOGIE BOX FITNESS.
WE ARE LOOKING FOR $700,000
TO LAUNCH OUR HOME DVD LINE.
IN EXCHANGE FOR THAT FUNDING,
WE ARE PREPARED TO OFFER
A 70% SHARE
IN OUR HOME DVD BUSINESS.
WHAT YOU JUST SAW WAS
A VERY SMALL SAMPLE
OF A BOOGIE BOX FITNESS
WORKOUT.
IT'S A FUSION OF HIP‐HOP,
LATIN DANCE, KICKBOXING,
PLYOMETRIC MOVEMENTS
AND HARD‐CORE
RESISTANCE TRAINING ALL IN ONE.
SO YOU'RE GETTING TWICE
THE WORKOUT IN HALF THE TIME.
DEDE, THAT DOESN'T LOOK
THAT EASY TO DO.
COME OVER HERE,
AND I'LL SHOW YOU RIGHT NOW.
(Barbara laughs)
ABSOLUTELY.
OKAY, I'M GONNA
SHOW YOU SOMETHING.
I'M A FIT GUY. I WAS ON
THE BIKE THIS MORNING.
OH, OKAY.
THESE SHARKS WERE NOT.
AND I'M GONNA SHOW YOU
WHAT MAKES THIS SPECIAL,
ABOUT APPLIED MUSCLE RESISTANCE,
OKAY?
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE USING
YOUR OWN BODY WEIGHT...
YEAH.
IN AN APPLIED MANNER‐‐
BOY, YOU ARE REALLY BUILT.
WHOA.
DON'T TOUCH THE TALENT, KEVIN.
OKAY, WHAT I WANT YOU TO DO...
OKAY.
ABS TIGHT.
I WANT YOU TO PRETEND
YOU HAVE WEIGHTS
IN YOUR HAND, OKAY?
YEAH, I'VE GOT IT.
OKAY, GRAB THOSE WEIGHTS,
AND WHAT I WANT YOU TO DO
IS THE SAME THING‐‐
PUT YOUR ELBOWS OUT,
AND SQUEEZE 'EM BACK DOWN.
YEAH.
PUT 'EM OUT
AND SQUEEZE 'EM BACK DOWN.
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GO FASTER.
AND UP AND DOWN. UP AND DOWN.
DEDE, IT LOOKS SO MUCH BETTER
WHEN YOU DO IT.
(sharks laugh)
THERE YOU GO. WHOO! THERE.
THAT'S CALLED KICK BUTT.
THIS IS HOW I KEEP
MY ADONIS FIGURE IN SHAPE.
YOU ARE DEFINITELY BUILT LIKE
A GOD‐‐BUDDHA, TO BE EXACT.
(sharks laugh)
I'M GONNA GO SIT DOWN
AND TALK ABOUT MONEY NOW.
THAT WAS FUN...
OKAY, GO SIT OVER THERE.
BUT NOW IT GETS TOUGH, DEDE.
BUT I JUST PROVED
THAT YOU CAN DO IT.
DO YOU HAVE ANY SALES
RIGHT NOW?
NOT FOR THE DVD PORTION
OF OUR BUSINESS, NO.
WE DO NOT ACTUALLY HAVE
A D‐‐
FOR ANY PORTION, ANY PORTION.
THERE IS ANOTHER PART
OF OUR BUSINESS
THAT IS CERTIFYING INSTRUCTORS,
TEACHING LIVE CLASSES,
DOING WORKSHOPS
FOR OUR STUDENTS.
THAT PART OF OUR BUSINESS, YES.
WE HAVE BEEN GROWING THAT.
WE LAUNCHED THAT
IN OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR.
KATHY, I WANT TO BE CLEAR.
YOU'RE SELLING ME ONLY THE DVD.
'CAUSE YOU‐‐YOU SAID THAT
VERY SPECIFICALLY.
YES, YES.
OKAY.
AND THE REASON WE DID THAT
IS THAT WE BELIEVE 80% TO 90%
OF OUR OVERALL REVENUE
IS GOING TO COME
DIRECTLY FROM THE DVD SALES.
AND WHAT‐‐WHAT REVENUE,
IF ANY,
COMES FROM THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE BUSINESS TODAY?
UH, YEAR TO DATE,
OUR REVENUE IS $15,000.
WHAT KIND OF FOLLOWING
DO YOU HAVE?
BECAUSE THIS IS, AS OF
RIGHT NOW, ANOTHER DANCE FORMAT.
WHERE IS THE FOLLOWING
AND/OR PROOF THAT YOU HAVE
THAT THIS WORKS?
CAN I SHOW YOU SOMETHING
THAT'LL HELP PROVE...
THIS IS BRENDA. BRENDA WAS
A MEMBER OF OUR TEST GROUP.
(Robert) HI, BRENDA.
BRENDA HAS LOST
100 POUNDS HERSELF
WITHIN SIX MONTHS
OF DOING BOOGIE BOX.
(Barbara) WOW.
(Robert) WOW.
AND IF THAT DOESN'T...
THAT'S IMPACTFUL.
SHE FITS IN ONE LEG NOW.
(Robert) THAT'S AMAZING.
(Daymond) THAT IS GREAT.
(O'Leary) LET'S TALK ABOUT MONEY
FOR A MINUTE.
OKAY.
IF I WAS GOING TO BE
PUTTING OUT $700,000‐‐
I LIKE THAT
JUST FLOWING OFF MY LIPS,
'CAUSE IT'S A HUGE AMOUNT
OF MONEY‐‐
YES, IT IS.
I'D HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
HOW I'D GET THAT BACK.
OUR SALES, CONSERVATIVELY,
WE HAVE ESTIMATED TO SELL
ONE MILLION UNITS
OVER THREE YEARS.
WE'VE COMPARED THAT TO WHAT
OUR COMPETITORS HAVE DONE‐‐
BUT STOP RIGHT THERE.
THEY SPENT A FORTUNE
PREPARING AN INFOMERCIAL
AND THEN BUYING
THE MEDIA TIME‐‐
AND THAT'S WHERE THE $700,000
COMES IN RIGHT THERE‐‐
THE MEDIA TIME.
YEAH, BUT YOU WANT TO MOVE
A MILLION CDs.
SOME OF THE TOP
RECORD ARTISTS TODAY
ARE NOT MOVING
THAT AMOUNT OF CDs,
AND THAT'S JUST MUSIC
TO LISTEN TO.
$700,000‐‐IT'S A VERY HARD
NUMBER FOR ME TO HIT
NOT KNOWING THIS BUSINESS.
SO I WOULD UNFORTUNATELY
HAVE TO SAY...
THAT I'M OUT.
HOW MUCH IS THE PRODUCTION
OF THE INFOMERCIAL?
$175,000.
(Robert) KATHY, ISN'T THERE
ANOTHER WAY YOU COULD DO THIS
INSTEAD OF BURNING THROUGH
$700,000?
YOU KNOW, IS IT A GO BIG
OR GO NOTHING PROPOSITION?
WE FEEL THAT THE RETURN
IS BETTER FOR EVERYBODY
IF WE PUT THAT INVESTMENT IN
UPFRONT ON THE SALES.
(Robert) YOU'RE ASKING ME
TO GIVE YOU $700,000,
AND WE HAVE NO WAY TO KNOW
IF IT'S GOING TO WORK
UNTIL THE MONEY'S GONE.
SO I EITHER...
GET MY MONEY BACK
OR I GET ZERO.
IT'S A LEAP OF FAITH.
AND I'M NOT WILLING
TO RISK MY MONEY
IN THAT BIG A LEAP OF FAITH.
I'M OUT.
KATHY, IS THAT
THE ONLY MODEL‐‐$700,000?
IT'S LIKE A FEATURE FILM.
IT'S A CRAPSHOOT.
WE HAVE ALIGNED OURSELVES
WITH PRODUCERS
WHO HAVE WORKED
WITH ALL OUR COMPETITORS.
THEY DO.
THEY FEEL VERY COMFORTABLE
AT WHAT WE'RE GONNA SELL...
VERY.
AND VERY COMFORTABLE
AT OUR PROJECTIONS.
I BELIEVE THERE'S A CRIME
CALLED MURDERING MONEY.
IF I GAVE YOU $700,000
AND YOU KILLED IT,
THEN I WOULD GO
INTO MONEY HELL.
SO FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
(mouths word)
OKAY.
YOUR WORKOUTS ARE GREAT,
BUT THERE IS NO BRAND HERE YET.
SO I HAVE TO SAY, I'M OUT.
HOW DID YOU EVEN
THINK OF THE BUSINESS?
I'M SO CURIOUS.
DEDE CREATED THIS.
THIS IS HER CREATION.
AFTER HAVING MY THIRD BABY,
I WAS 204 POUNDS.
I USED TO BE
A PROFESSIONAL DANCER
FOR MANY YEARS,
AND A CHOREOGRAPHER,
AND I STOPPED WHEN I HAD
MY FIRST CHILD.
AND I JUST WAS NOT
AT HAPPY PLACE IN MY LIFE.
SO, UM... I'VE USED ALL MY
TRAINING AS A CHOREOGRAPHER
AND A FIGHTER,
AND I LOST ALL THE WEIGHT.
IT TOOK ME 7 MONTHS TO LOSE
65 POUNDS DOING THIS FORMAT.
IT'S WORKED ON ME,
IT'S WORKED ON BRENDA,
AND IT'S CHANGING
EVERYBODY'S LIVES‐‐
NOT JUST THEIR BODIES,
BUT THEIR LIVES.
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT I LIKE
ABOUT WHAT I'M HEARING.
I LOVE THE BRAND NAME.
BOOGIE BOX‐‐SO COOL.
I ALSO LOVE THE FACT
THAT YOU'RE 100% GENUINE,
FROM YOUR STORY
TO WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
TO HOW GENUINELY
YOU'RE ANSWERING THE QUESTIONS.
♪♪
FOUR SHARKS ARE OUT.
BARBARA IS DEDE'S AND KATHY'S
LAST CHANCE TO GET A DEAL.
I LOVE THE BRAND NAME.
BOOGIE BOX‐‐SO COOL.
I ALSO LOVE THE FACT
THAT YOU'RE 100% GENUINE,
FROM YOUR STORY
TO WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
TO HOW GENUINELY
YOU'RE ANSWERING THE QUESTIONS.
BUT I THINK YOU MADE
A TERRIBLE MISTAKE HERE,
WHICH IS GONNA COST YOU,
AND THAT IS,
YOU ASKED FOR TOO MUCH MONEY.
IF YOU HAD COME IN HERE
AND OFFERED US
A BITE‐SIZED PIECE
WITH A BITE‐SIZED TEST,
YOU'D HAVE ALL THESE GUYS
ALL OVER YOU.
THAT'S A GREAT POINT.
BUT YOU DIDN'T,
AND SO I'M OUT.
(woman) OKAY.
(Kathy) OKAY.
WELL, WE THANK YOU.
(O'Leary)
ALL RIGHT, YOU GUYS.
♪♪
THEY DON'T KNOW ANY BETTER,
AND THEY WANT TO MAKE
THE PERFECT PRODUCT TOO FAST.
THEY WENT
FOR THE HOLLYWOOD APPROACH
INSTEAD OF THE OFF‐BROADWAY.
IF THEY DO IT SMALL,
THEY WILL GROW,
AND THEY WILL BE A SUCCESS.
BOOGIE BOX FITNESS
DOES NOT DIE HERE TODAY.
OH, NO, NO, NO, NO.
OH, NO. IT GETS BIGGER.
WORLD DOMINATION.
(laughs)
NEXT UP IS SAWYER SPARKS,
A COLLEGE STUDENT
WITH BIG AMBITIONS
FOR HIS SMALL HOMETOWN.
♪♪
MY NAME IS SAWYER SPARKS.
I'M 22 YEARS OLD.
I'M FROM BLOOMFIELD, INDIANA,
AND I'M A COLLEGE STUDENT.
MY FIRST YEAR OF COLLEGE,
ONE OF MY FAVORITE PROFESSORS
AND HER 5‐YEAR‐OLD CHILD
MENTIONED THAT THEY HAD
CELIAC DISEASE,
WHICH MEANS
THEY WERE ALLERGIC TO WHEAT.
BECAUSE OF THIS ALLERGY,
HER CHILD COULD NOT PLAY WITH
THE TRADITIONAL MODELING CLAY,
LIKE PLAY‐DOH,
THAT WE ALL GREW UP WITH
BECAUSE THEY ALL CONTAIN WHEAT.
SO I CREATED SOY‐YER‐DOUGH,
A WHEAT‐FREE, SOY‐BASED
MODELING CLAY.
WELCOME TO
THE WORLD HEADQUARTERS
OF SOY‐YER‐DOUGH
IN MY MOM'S KITCHEN.
AND THIS IS MY MOM SUE.
SHE DOES ALL THE KNEADING.
THIS IS MY GIRLFRIEND SAMMIE,
WHO DOES ALL THE MIXING.
AND I DO ALL THE STIRRING
HERE AT THE STOVE.
AND WE DO THIS DAY IN
AND DAY OUT,
EVERY DAY WITH ORDERS.
THIS BUSINESS
ISN'T JUST ABOUT MAKING MONEY.
IT'S ABOUT HELPING
ALL THE PEOPLE
IN THE COMMUNITY
THAT I GREW UP WITH.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YES, THANK YOU.
GLAD TO SEE YOU COME HOME.
WHAT I REALLY WANT TO DO
IS EXPAND MY BUSINESS,
OPEN UP A FACTORY
IN BLOOMFIELD, INDIANA,
AND CREATE JOBS
IN MY COMMUNITY.
♪♪
MY NAME IS SAWYER SPARKS,
AND MY PRODUCT IS SOY‐YER‐DOUGH.
I'M ASKING FOR
A $125,000 INVESTMENT
FOR 25% OF MY COMPANY.
THE TRADITIONAL MODELING CLAY
THAT WE ALL GREW UP WITH
IS WHEAT BASED,
WHICH CAUSES CHILDREN
WITH AN AVERSION TO WHEAT
TO FEEL COMPLETELY LEFT OUT.
SO I INVENTED SOY‐YER‐DOUGH‐‐
THE FIRST AND ONLY
PATENTED MODELING CLAY
THAT IS GLUTEN‐FREE,
NONTOXIC AND FUN‐SCENTED.
OH, IT SMELLS LIKE CHERRY.
YES, AND IT SMELLS BEST
IF YOU BREAK 'EM APART.
WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF THE CHILDREN POPULATION
HAVE THIS PROBLEM?
ACTUALLY, 1 IN 8 CHILDREN.
OUR COMPETITOR SELLS
96 MILLION CONTAINERS
OF THIS SIZE A YEAR.
ONE‐EIGHTH OF THAT IS
12 MILLION CONTAINERS PER YEAR.
SO THERE'S A HUGE MARKET
FOR THIS.
HOW‐‐HOW MUCH OF THIS
HAVE YOU SOLD SO FAR?
WE HAVE SOLD 8,000 CONTAINERS
SINCE FEBRUARY.
UH, THAT'S WHEN THIS BEGAN,
AND WE JUST LAST WEEK GOT
AN ORDER FOR 11,000 CONTAINERS.
WOW.
THE 8,000 YOU SOLD WERE
A RESULT OF YOUR ONLINE SALES?
ONLINE SALES.
HOW PROPRIETARY
IS THIS PRODUCT?
IS THERE A PATENT
OF ANY KIND ON IT?
YES, MINE. IT HAS
A PROVISIONAL PATENT ON IT.
WHERE ARE YOU
MANUFACTURING THIS?
OUT OF MY KITCHEN
AT HOME, ACTUALLY.
H‐HOW ARE YOU DOING THAT?
UH, IT'S MY MOM,
ME AND MY GIRLFRIEND‐‐
YOU JUST COOK IT YOURSELF?
WE JUST
COOK IT OURSELVES, YES.
WE CAN ONLY MAKE 12 CONTAINERS,
UH, PER 10 MINUTES.
HAVE YOU APPROACHED
ANY TOY MAKERS?
WE HAVE AN OFFER‐‐
HAVE YOU TRIED TO
LICENSE THIS TO PLAY‐DOH?
I HAVE BEEN CONTACTED
BY PLAY‐DOH, THOUGH.
FOR WHAT?
ABOUT‐‐ABOUT THIS,
TO PURCHASE IT.
WAIT. WAIT.
AND WHAT HAPPENED?
AND WHAT DID THEY HAVE TO SAY?
THEY LOVE IT, THEY WANT IT,
AND WE'RE‐‐
WE'VE BEEN NEGOTIATING
BECAUSE THEY WANT
THIS PATENT.
SO THE LARGEST PLAYER
IN THE SPACE CONTACTED YOU...
MULTIPLE TIMES.
TO LICENSE YOUR PATENT.
SORRY. MULTIPLE TIMES?
MULTIPLE TIMES.
AND WHERE IS THAT NEGOTIATION
AT THIS POINT?
AT THIS POINT, I WANT TO
CREATE JOBS IN MY COMMUNITY‐‐
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT,
WAIT, WAIT.
YOU WANT TO SIT
IN YOUR MOTHER'S KITCHEN TABLE
BAKING THIS STUFF,
WHEN THE NUMBER ONE GUY
IN THE WORLD IS CALLING YOU?
ARE YOU NUTS?
NO, HE WANTS
THE WHOLE NEIGHBORHOOD
TO SIT IN HIS MOTHER'S KITCHEN
BAKING THIS STUFF.
WHY WOULD YOU BAKE
ONE MORE CUP OF THIS STUFF
WHEN THE NUMBER ONE GUY ON EARTH
IS BANGING AT YOUR DOOR?
BECAUSE I‐‐
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT MOMENT
FOR YOU,
'CAUSE IT'S GONNA TELL ME
WHETHER YOU'RE SANE OR INSANE.
NO, BECAUSE HONESTLY,
I REALLY FEEL THAT IF THEY
PURCHASE THIS PATENT FROM ME,
WE WOULD NEVER SEE IT AGAIN
IN THE LIGHT OF DAY.
WAIT, WAIT,
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
(Robert) SAWYER‐‐
MAYBE THAT'S TRUE,
BUT HOW MUCH
ARE THEY GOING
TO PURCHASE IT FOR?
THAT'S STILL IN NEGOT‐‐
NEGOTIATION.
IS IT‐‐DO YOU NEED SOME HELP
IN NEGOTIATING THAT?
YEAH.
HAVE THEY MADE YOU
AN ACTUAL OFFER?
UH, THROUGH MY LAWYERS,
BUT NOT...
WHAT WAS THEIR PRICE?
THERE'S BEEN
DIFFERENT OFFERS.
THE HIGHEST HAS BEEN AROUND
$500,000.
YOU HAD AN OFFER FOR $500,000?
YOU'RE A COLLEGE STUDENT‐‐
BUT I REALLY FEEL
THAT IN A YEAR,
TWO YEARS DOWN THE ROAD,
I CAN HONESTLY SELL
12 MILLION OF THESE CONTAINERS.
ARE YOU A WEALTHY GUY,
SAWYER?
NO.
DIDN'T THE $500,000‐‐I'M JUST
CURIOUS‐‐DIDN'T IT TEMPT YOU?
TEMPTED MY PARENTS, YES.
WHAT ABOUT YOUR GIRLFRIEND?
YES. (laughs)
(laughs)
WHAT'S YOUR IDEA ABOUT
EMPLOYING PEOPLE?
I JUST FEEL LIKE I DON'T HAVE MY
FINGER ON YOUR MOTIVATION HERE.
MY MOTIVATION
IS TO CREATE JOBS,
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
A PRODUCT FOR THESE‐‐
ONE‐EIGHTH OF THE MARKET‐‐
PLAY‐DOH CAN DO THAT.
NOT WITH
A WHEAT‐FREE MAR‐‐
YOU'RE SURE
YOUR PATENT EXCLUDES THEM
FROM EVER DOING
A WHEAT‐FREE PRODUCT?
YES, YES.
OUTSTANDING, YOUNG MAN.
OUTSTANDING.
I RARELY SEE AN OPPORTUNITY LIKE
THIS FROM THE LICENSE FRONT.
THIS IS
A WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU.
SAWYER‐‐OH.
SAWYER, I HAVE GREAT NEWS
FOR YOU.
THANK GOODNESS WE'VE MET.
MY WHOLE BUSINESS CAREER
WAS BUILT AROUND
LICENSING PROPERTIES.
DONE IT HUNDREDS OF TIMES.
I'LL GIVE YOU $125,000
FOR 51% OF YOUR PATENT.
AND I'LL TELL YOU
WHY I'M DOING THAT.
I'M DOING IT...
TO TAKE YOU
OUT OF THE EQUATION.
AND I PROMISE YOU,
YOU'LL GET A BETTER DEAL
THAN THE ONE
YOU'RE GETTING RIGHT NOW
WHEN I SIT DOWN
WITH YOUR FRIENDS AT PLAY‐DOH.
SAWYER SAID NO TO HALF A MILLION
IN CASH FROM PLAY‐DOH.
BUT YOU'RE PROPOSING‐‐
HE'S GONNA MAKE MUCH MORE
THAN HALF A MILLION
WHEN I'M YOUR PARTNER‐‐
MUCH MORE, MUCH MORE.
BUT YOU'RE TAKING CONTROL.
HE'S‐‐YES,
BECAUSE I SHOULD SIT‐‐
SO YOU COULD SELL IT
FOR $600,000.
I DON'T‐‐
THERE'S NOTHING HE CAN DO.
ROBERT, YOU'RE JUST
MAKING NOISE TO ME.
LOOK, KEVIN‐‐
SAWYER, LET ME SWEETEN MY OFFER,
'CAUSE THIS IS NOISE.
I'M TIRED OF LISTENING TO IT.
HERE'S A BETTER DEAL FOR YOU.
WE'LL KEEP IT THIS WAY‐‐
51% AT $125,000,
AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO CLOSE
UNTIL I FINISH THE NEGOTIATIONS
WITH THESE GUYS.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE THE DEAL,
WALK AWAY.
I'M GONNA BE
YOUR ADVOCATE RIGHT NOW,
BECAUSE I KNOW ABOUT LICENSING,
BUT HONESTLY,
I THINK HE IS GIVING YOU
AN INCREDIBLE DEAL.
I'D CONSIDER THIS
WHAT WE CALL A "YOLO" MOMENT.
YOU ONLY LIVE ONCE.
ALL RIGHT?
YES.
AND TO MAKE SURE
THAT I DON'T COMPETE,
'CAUSE I THINK THAT IS
A REALLY GOOD DEAL...
I'M OUT.
I'M GONNA GET RID
OF THE CLUTTER.
UM, I THINK A SPECIALIST
IN LICENSING
LIKE KEVIN O'LEARY IS‐‐
IS A GOOD PARTNER TO HAVE,
SO I‐‐I'M GONNA BOW OUT.
OKAY.
HE'S THE NATURAL PARTNER
FOR YOU,
AND I DON'T EVEN LIKE THE GUY,
SO FOR ME TO ENDORSE HIM
IS SHOCKING TO MYSELF.
I'M OUT.
SO YOU JUST WANT TO RAISE
SOME CASH TO DO WHAT?
UH, TO BUILD A FACILITY
IN MY COMMUNITY.
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING,
MY FRIEND,
I'VE BEEN RICH
AND I'VE BEEN POOR.
RICH IS MUCH BETTER,
AND I WANT TO GET YOU THERE.
YOU'LL FIND MANY WAYS
TO CREATE JOBS
WHEN YOU HAVE THE CAPITAL
TO BUILD BUSINESS.
COULD I ASK YOU A QUESTION?
YES.
HOW MUCH DO YOU LOVE MONEY?
DO YOU LOVE IT AS MUCH AS I DO?
PROBABLY NOT.
I'M STILL IN COL‐‐
I'M A COLLEGE STUDENT AND...
(laughs)
I JUST NEED MONEY
FOR BEER, I GUESS,
IS WHAT THIS IS.
(sharks laugh)
(O'Leary)
THIS IS SUCH WHAT I DO.
THIS IS IN MY BLOOD,
WHAT YOU'RE DOING HERE.
THERE'S NO PERSON
BETTER ON EARTH
TO BE IN YOUR SHOES THAN ME.
BELIEVE ME. WE NEED TO BE
PARTNERS ON THIS.
ARE WE GONNA BE IN BUSINESS
OR NOT?
I LOVE YOUR OFFER.
AND I DEFINITELY FEEL
THAT I DO NEED HELP,
UH, WITH THIS, AND, UH,
BUT NOT FOR 51%.
♪♪
COULD YOU DO $125,000
FOR 40%?
HERE'S THE PROBLEM‐‐
LET ME EXPLAIN THE PROBLEM.
UM...
THE REASON I NEED 51%
IS, WHEN I BEGIN NEGOTIATIONS,
THE OTHER SIDE HAS TO KNOW
THAT I HAVE
THE ABILITY TO CLOSE.
BUT I COULD STILL GIVE YOU
THE ABILITY TO CLOSE ON‐‐
NO. YOU SEE,
HAVING NEGOTIATED THIS LICENSE
HUNDREDS OF TIMES BEFORE,
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO TRUST ME.
I WOULD NEVER, EVER DO THIS
WITHOUT HAVING THE ABILITY
TO GO IN THERE
AND COME BACK WITH A DEAL
THAT'S SIGNIFICANTLY SUPERIOR.
IF YOU TELL ME
ONE OF THE ATTRIBUTES
IS YOU HAVE TO CREATE JOBS,
I'LL GET THAT FOR YOU.
I AM WILLING TO BEND OVER
BACKWARDS TO GET YOU HAPPY
IN THE STRUCTURE OF THE DEAL,
BUT I HAVE TO WALK IN THERE
WITH 51%,
AND I SWEAR,
I'LL COME OUT OF THERE
WITH SOMETHING
YOU CAN'T EVEN DREAM OF.
SAWYER, IT'S A GREAT SPEECH...
AND IT'S TRUE.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT, SAWYER?
I ALMOST BELIEVED
IT FOR A SECOND.
BUT I THINK YOU DID
AN EXCELLENT JOB TODAY
OF SEEING THROUGH
THE FLUFFINESS
AND INTO WHAT IT REALLY IS,
JUST GREED.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $125,000
FOR THE 40%.
SO WE'RE‐‐WE'RE‐‐
(whimpers) I'M GONNA CRY.
I CAN'T TAKE IT.
SAWYER HAS TWO OFFERS
ON THE TABLE.
KEVIN O'LEARY
HAS OFFERED $125,000
FOR 51% OF THE COMPANY.
BUT ROBERT HAS OUTBID HIM,
OFFERING THE SAME AMOUNT
FOR ONLY 40% OF THE COMPANY.
WHAT'S YOUR‐‐
WHAT'S YOUR PLAN?
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
WAIT, WAIT. HE'S NEVER, EVER‐‐
I'VE DONE WHAT I'VE
JUST DESCRIBED TO YOU
A HUNDRED TIMES, AND THE PROOF
IS IN THE PUDDING.
MY ONLY PROBLEM IS THAT
I NEED‐‐I NEED OWNERSHIP.
I DON'T WANT OWNERSHIP.
WHAT I WANT IS THE ABILITY
TO CLOSE.
WITH 51%.
I‐‐
YOU CAN'T CLOSE IF YOU
OWN LESS THAN 51?
LIKE, THAT DOESN'T EVEN
MAKE SENSE?
NO, IT DOES MAKE SENSE.
THE REASON YOU DON'T KNOW THIS
IS YOU'VE NEVER DONE IT,
WHICH IS WHY HIS OFFER
IS USELESS TO YOU.
OKAY.
YOU NEED A GUY
THAT'S ACTUALLY DONE IT.
SAWYER, I'M NOT‐‐I'M NOT...
(Daymond) YOU HAVE
TWO OFFERS ON THE TABLE.
I'M NOT GONNA SELL YOU THAT
HARD. I DON'T FEEL I NEED TO.
RIGHT.
I THINK YOU'RE A SMART GUY.
I THINK YOU DID A GOOD JOB.
I THINK THAT, UH, YOU'RE
VERY CLEAR WITH WHAT YOU WANT.
WITH THAT OFFER, WHAT‐‐WHAT IS
YOUR PLANS WITH THIS BUSINESS?
I MEAN, I THINK
THAT MY PLAN WITH IT
IS TO KEEP DOING
WHAT YOU'RE DOING,
NEGOTIATE HARD WITH PLAY‐DOH
AND TRY TO GET MONEY.
I'M REALLY IMPRESSED
BY WHAT YOU'VE BUILT.
IT'S $125,000.
WE DO BOTH‐‐
NEGOTIATE WITH PLAY‐DOH,
KEEP SELLING IT.
I MEAN, YOU SOLD 11,000 UNITS.
IT'S‐‐IT'S REMARKABLE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO SAY.
SO YOU HAVE
TWO DEALS ON THE TABLE.
ONE WHO WANTS TO CONTROL
YOUR COMPANY,
THE OTHER ONE WHO DOESN'T KNOW
ABOUT LICENSING.
YOU KNOW,
THE‐‐THE‐‐THE PROBLEM...
AND I UNDERSTAND YOUR CONCERN
ABOUT THE 51%,
AND I'M‐‐I'M STRUGGLING,
BECAUSE‐‐
IF THE 51%
WITH YOU CAN'T CHANGE,
THEN GIVE ME
A BETTER MONEY OFFER.
♪♪
IS MY OFFER OFF THE TABLE,
SAWYER?
NO, I'M NOT SAYING THAT.
WHAT'S MOST IMPORTANT TO ME
IS THAT
WE ARE GOING TO GO DOWN
THE PATH TO NEGOTIATE A LICENSE.
THAT'S WHAT MATTERS TO ME.
RIGHT.
IF YOU ALLOW HIM TO NEGOTIATE
ON YOUR BEHALF WITH 51%,
THEN I'LL GIVE YOU $200,000.
DAYMOND HAS COME BACK IN,
ADDING $200,000
TO KEVIN O'LEARY'S OFFER
IF SAWYER WILL ALLOW KEVIN
TO NEGOTIATE FOR HIM.
I'LL GO DOWN THAT ROAD.
I'LL PUT IN ANOTHER $125,000.
LET'S DO THIS. EACH OF US
IS GOING TO PUT IN $100,000,
FOR A TOTAL OF $300,000
FOR 51% OF THE COMPANY.
AND YOU KNOW
WHY IT HAS TO BE 51%.
THAT'S THE OFFER.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
THE SHARKS HAVE OFFERED SAWYER
$175,000 MORE
THAN WHAT HE CAME IN SEEKING,
BUT HE MUST GIVE UP 51%
OF HIS COMPANY.
♪♪
WE'RE GONNA MAKE A LOT OF DOUGH
WITH THIS DOUGH.
CONGRATULATIONS, GUYS.
LET'S DO THIS.
ALL RIGHT.
YES. YES.
(Barbara) WOW. ONE LUCKY KID,
LET ME TELL YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
(Robert) SURE.
VERY IMPRESSIVE.
(O'Leary) ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
(Robert) I FEEL BETTER
ABOUT THAT END OF THE DEAL.
(Barbara) GREAT.
LOOK, I HAD TO HAVE THAT.
YOU GUYS, YOU WANT ME
TO BE REALLY HONEST?
(O'Leary) YEAH.
YOU GUYS SCREWED ME OUT OF
ONE OR TWO DEALS.
I WAS JUST BOTCHING IT.
I DIDN'T EVEN THINK
I WAS GONNA GET IN THERE.
BUT I'M IN, BABY!
YEAH. (laughs)
(laughs)
IT'S A GREAT DEAL
FOR MY COMMUNITY,
AND IT'S FOR YOU,
BLOOMFIELD, INDIANA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, EVERYBODY,
FOR YOUR COMMUNITY AND SUPPORT.
NEXT WEEK ON "SHARK TANK"...
YOU'VE SOLD 10,000 BELTS?
YES.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT HE'S SOLD
THAT MANY UNITS.
NO, I CAN BACK THAT UP,
OF COURSE.
THROX LIKES TO DO THINGS
IN THREES.
AND WE AIM TO PLEASE
WE'RE GONNA MAKE YOU
$24 MILLION IN 4 YEARS.
I'LL BET
HALF MY COMPANY ON IT.
WHAT?
WOW.
YOU'RE JUST TAKING OUR MONEY
AND SCREWING US. YOU'RE A PIG.
THIS GUY WILL EAT YOU
FOR BREAKFAST. HE'S AN ANIMAL.
YOU'RE GONNA CORRUPT
THESE YOUNG MINDS, BARBARA.
I DON'T THINK THESE GUYS
ARE THAT DUMB.